I've been alerted to a situation.
It's been happening a lot lately.
People have been seeing those photos on social media...
...and are going to great lengths to copy them.
I mean, you know them.
"Hot tub, back shot."
"Man sits quietly on a rock, contemplating."
"Hotdog legs."
And the classic one in these parts, "The Summit Spreadeagle."
Okay, easy does it, sir.
Lower those arms nice and slow.
Hi guys, I've seen all this before, yeah.
We all have,...
...but this summer,...
...we're clamping down on anyone traveling under the social influence. Okay?
Come on guys, you've had your fun.
Trust me, you're going to absolutely love it.
Okay, hop out you two.
You can consider this a warning, guys.
Enjoy the wineries on those bikes,...
...and don't forget to share something new, okay?
It's just really hard sometimes, you know,...
...because there are so many great other photos to take besides your usual 'Gram' shots.
What you need to do is you need to think outside the square or triangle.